[Müzik]
bugünün konsepti oyun ve oyun benim için
Hayal kurmak motivasyon ve stratejinin
bir noktada birleşimi gibi bir şey ben
Merhaba ben Sabri Canan Yontar ve
Türkiye'deki her insan gibi İşte önce
bir lise giriş sınavı sonra lise
sonrasında üniversite giriş sınavı
derken stresli bir periyotun sonunda Tam
da istediğim olmadı istediğim puanı
alamadım ve iki uçak mühendisliği
istiyordum fakat çok ufak bir puan farkı
yaşadıktan sonra uzay mühendisliğine
yerleştirdim hemen hemen aynı bir bölüm
ama hayatım böyle içilirse bir noktada
2015 yılında Erasmus deneyim oldu ve
Yunanistan'da uçak mühendisliği okumuş
oldum Aslında oradan bir noktada yeni
uçak mühendisliğine olay edilmiş oldu
sonrasında mezun oldum ne yapacağımı tam
olarak bilemediğim için önce bir Master
yapmaya karar verdim fakat Belli bir
yerden sonra İstediğim gibi bir Param
olmadığı için aslında Tamam dedim ben
artık uçak mühendisliği
hayat devam ederken şu anda Yani çok
farklı bir şey
bant ve
içerik üretiyorum satranç üzerine Ya
hikâye aslında oyun çok daha Eskileri
dayanıyor böyle Ben küçükken sürekli
Hayal etmeyi çok seviyorum Böyle işte
oyuncaklarımla ya da belki birazcık daha
büyüdü büyüdükten sonra aslında
bir şekilde böyle hayatını bir hayalin
üzerine kurmaya başladım oyundaki Hayal
üzerine İşte o zamanlar öyle kardeşim
veren 5 yaş küçük bir kardeşim var ve o
her zaman benimle beraber böyle bir oyun
arkadaşı oldu o yüzden böyle oyunların
kurabiliyordum ve sürekli benle
oynayacak biri de vardım hayatımda hep
mesela Formula bizi çok seviyordum ve
formülü bir aracını silmek de çok
istiyordu mesela küçükken ama böyle bir
şey imkan yok fakat biz kendi Kafamızda
böyle bir şeyler oluşturup ve Formula 1
gibi işte halıların kenarlarına böyle
yol olarak düşünüp oralara böyle
bisikletleri diziyorduk ve o
bisikletleri yarıştırmaya çalışıyorduk O
benim için böyle şey gibi yani sanki o
oyunun içinde kendimizi hissediyorum
Yani o sporun içinde kendimi
hissediyorum gibi hissediyorum Yani
bugüne kadar Aslında ne yapmak istesem
hep böyle kendimi hep oraya koymaya
çalışıyorum Mesela diyelim ki bir ev
kiralamak istiyorum ve evin içinde böyle
yani sadece bir kiralamayı düşünüyorum
diyorum ki evin içinde mesela
arkadaşları geliyor onlarla beraber çay
içiyoruz işte Mutfağa gidiyorum
oturuyorum Film izliyorum Hep bu tarz
şey aslında bir noktada hiç konuşmama ve
ben 3 sene önce de hayal ediyorum ya
böyle bir hikayenin sonucu güzel bir
başarıya çıksa dedekse Sonra işte
izleyicilere baksam direkt böyle hayal
ediyordum
Böyle hayal ettiğinizde bazı şeyler
gerçekten başarıya ulaşıyor şimdi belki
size şey gibi
gelir İnan başarırsın işte bunu yaparsın
gibi bir şey geçecek ama aslında tam
olarak
öyle değil motivasyonel söz gibi bir şey
değil ben o hayali o kadar böyle
inandırıcı kurmaya çalışıyorum ki ve o
hayali yaşıyorum ki Aslında o hayaline
ulaşana kadar bir noktada o beni motive
ediyor ve Aslında sosyal medyada bir
kişilik üretime olayı da bir noktada tam
olarak böyle başladı diyebilirim
üniversitede satranç kulübündeyiz Ya şu
anki gibi satrancayı yayma olayı orada
üniversitede vardı ve bir standımız
vardı ve o standı böyle olabildiğince
üniversiteden insanları çekmeye
çalışıyorduk böyle bir misyon
verilebilir Sebebini bilmiyorum ama
herkesin işte satranç oynatacağız bir
şekilde İstanbul Teknik Üniversitesi'nde
ve sonra bir arkadaşım böyle mümini hiç
unutmuyorum arkadaşımın bir arkadaşıydı
ve geçerken dedi ki ya sen de katıl
istersen
çok sıkıcı demiştim ya o an böyle şeyi
hisset
tim
10 Dakikam olsa sana satrancığım çok
güzelliklerini anlatabilsem Eğer keyifli
olabildiğine anlatabilsem diye böyle
düşünmüştüm ve Aslında böyle bir hayal
sonrasında Türkiye'de bunu anlatmaya
kadar bir noktada geldi Tabi hikayeye
baştan anlatırken uçak mühendisliğine
2018'de başladım dediniz şu anda içerik
üretiyorum Tabi bu süreci gelirken
2018'de ben aynı zamanda kanala devam
ediyordum Ama çok da iyi yabancı
sayılarımız yoktu böyle bir sene
uğraşmıştık ama olmuyordu ve dedim ki
Tamam ben uçak mühendisi olmaya devam
edeceğim hayatında derken ya böyle yine
kaderimin cilvesi tam başladığım O hafta
videolarım izlenmeye başladı ve böyle
kanalımız çok fazla artıyor abone sayısı
ve bir anda böyle 20.000 abonelere falan
geldi o arada para da kazanmaya başladım
ve dedim ki yaptık Galiba ileride bir iş
oluyor yani hayatımı artık şey gibi oldu
sonra 6'da işten çıkıyorum ve gidiyorum
eve yemek yedikten sonra video çekiyorum
Yani bütün ve iş günlerim böyle olmaya
başladı ve sonrasında bir yerde şey
düşünmeye başladım
acaba bu Tam zamanlı bir işe dönüşecek
mi Tabi bu kararı vermek o kadar kolay
değil yani biz satranç oyunu gibi
düşünelim satranç önünde böyle ya
aslında satranç da benim hayatıma
kattığı şeylerden bir tanesi çikolata
artık yaşayamıyorum sürekli kafamda şey
düşünüyorum Hani bazen vardır ya Her
şeyi bırak böyle istediğini yap öyle bir
şansım Aslında
Satrançta satranç oynuyorsunuz Eğer
böyle bir şansınız yok Çünkü sürekli
Düşünmeniz lazım ya ben bu hamle
yapacağım rakipten böyle bir anda
gelecek ben buna karşılık bunu yapacağım
ya da işte sürekli bir ev planları c
planları hangi taşı nereye koyacağım
hayatta da Yine yapıyoruz aslında bir
noktadan ve
uçak mühendisliğini bırakıp en Aslında
ben bunları hepsine hesaplıyorum satranç
oynuyorum ama
zorluk yaşıyorum yani Sadece 5 senelik
bir eğitiminizi bırakmıyorsunuz aslında
bir daha geri dönmek için
bırakacaksınız ve onu da şeyle mesela
uçak mühendisliğini bırakabiliyorsunuz
kod öğrendiniz bilgisayar mühendisi ya
da Mühendislik alanlarını
değiştireceksiniz bu tarz bir şey değil
yani içerik üreteceksin zaten
[Müzik]
Uşak mühendisiyle hiçbir alakası yok
işte siz piyasası yaptınız Hiç konum
değerlendirmesini yaptınız işte
satrançtaki gibi ki ben de öyle
yapmıştım ve işimi bıraktıktan sonra
hayat Aslında böyle pek de planlamadığım
hamleleri yazdı yani Ben zaten hani bunu
planlamıştım işte bir sene böyle
geçecekti falan diye düşünmeye
çalışırken Aslında şeylerin de bir
noktada değiştiğini gördüm artık
uçak mühendisini bıraktığımda kendi
kafamda şeydi Hani bir sene kendime ara
verdim ve deneyeceğim diye düşünürken
çevrem çok farklı Aslında davranmaya
başladı ve statü olarak düştüğünü fark
ettim Artık uçak mühendisi değilim işsiz
biriyim ve bir anda böyle çevreden
sürekli baskı geliyor arkadaşlarım
sürekli tavsiyeler veriyor Bak yanlış
bir şey yaptın Aslında geri dönmen
gerekiyor ya da bunu denememiydim artık
Çok da geçti kararımı verdim bir noktada
Orada insanlar bile ses çıkmasını
bekliyorsun ama insanlarda kendince
haklı olduğu şeyi açıklıyorlar sana ve
onun üstüne bir de kötü olarak sosyal
medyada istediğim böyle artışı da
yapamadım istediğim paraları da
kazanamadım ve sonra bir anda şey gibi
oluyor şimdi konumu değerlendirdiğiniz
Satrançta ediyorsunuz ki ya ben planım
belli ama sonrasında diyorsunuz ki ben
burada ilk arıyorum Bu konu benim niye
abla sonra etrafı sürekli size Yok hayır
kötü durumdasın bak diye hatırlatınca
Siz de kendiniz Aslında motivasyonunuzu
bile ortada şey diye düşünmeye
başlıyorsunuz
ya belki de yanılıyorum belki insanlara
Belki de gerçekten kötü durumdayım diye
ama sonra kendime sürekli hatırlattığım
bir şey vardı hatta geçtiğimiz senede
biter Bir podcase denk geldim tişört
firması Kuran bir kişinin kopyasını
şöyle bir şey geçiyordu Aslında 18
yaşındaki halinin verdiği bir karar
üniversite bölüm kararı nasıl bütün
hayatını etkileyebilir yani O mesela
üniversiteyi bırakmış ve devamında
bir tişört firması kurmuş ve başarılı
olmuş ve herkes başarılı olmayabilir ama
yine de mantık aslında şu mesela 18
yaşındaki beni ele alırım
sınavda istediği puanı yapamadı Hatta
uzay mühendisliği de kazanmak gerekiyor
uçakta bağlantılı olarak söylüyorum uçak
istiyordu ama olmadı başka bir bölüme
gideceğim ve mutlu olmadım şimdi ne
yapacak yani bu kişi 65 yaşına kadar
ne yapacaksın ya da diyelim ki gerçekten
Başarılı oldu uçak mühendislik bir
kazandı
ve sonrasında
dedi ki girdi
işe girdi ama işte beğenmedi ya da hadi
işte de çok güzel gitti her şey Ama 35
yaşına geldi ve dedi ki Tutkusu kayboldu
dedi ki ben bunu yapmayacağım şimdi o
noktadan sonra eğer bir dönüş Yoksa
Hayat aslında birazcık daha
zorlaşmıyorum yani 60 yaşına kadar 65
yaşına kadar siz bu aynı işi
yapacaksanız gerçekten hayat belki
çekilmez bir noktaya gelecek Ben de
kendi kararımı verirken Aslında şey diye
düşündüm yani 40 yıl boyunca emekli
olana kadar bir bölüm tercih kararı
hayatımıza etkileyemez bu bana doğru
gelmiyor En azından onu söyleyebilirim
ve tabii çevremizi de hep gördüğümüz şey
işte mezun oluyorsunuz güzel bir iş
buluyorsunuz diyelim ki ya da bir işte
güzel bir eş buluyorsunuz diyorsunuz ki
Tamam Ben hayatımı birleştireceğim
sonrasında işte çocuk sahibi oluyorsunuz
ve işinizde de yükseliyorsunuz her şey
Hani normal gidiyor işte bu çevre size
aslında bir noktada bunu bunu veriyor
Diyor ki Tamam yani doğru iş olan şey bu
ve bunun dışında farklı bir şey yapmak
hiç kolay değil ve Konfor alanınızdan da
çıkıyorsunuz Çünkü belli bir maaşınızı
vermeniz lazım yani benim 2019'daki
yaşadığım o istifa ettikten sonraki
durum birazcık benim için yorucuydu
Çünkü çevreden destek gelmiyor bir
noktada Hani istediğiniz desek Yani
tabii ki destek veren insanlar var Aile
bazı arkadaşlarınız buna destek veriyor
ama o olay içerisinde gerçekten
durumunuz böyle nasıl biliyor musunuz
Hani Hem para kazanamıyorsunuz
istediğiniz gibi hem çok uğraşmanız
lazım Bir de benim motivasyonlarımdan
bir tanesi şuydu ya 9-6 İşte çalışırken
Salı günü diyelim ki saat 13.00'te
işinizin olduğu yerden çok uzak bir
noktada bir arkadaşınızla çay içme
ihtimaliniz yok Şimdi diyordum ki ya
Böyle bir şey olabilir ama 9-6 yaşı
bırakınca da bir de şöyle bir şey oluyor
o kadar böyle hayatla beraber iç
içesiniz ve yaptığınız işi oldurmaya
çalışıyorsunuz ki artık şey de yok Gidip
orada çay içme imkanınız da yok Çünkü
artık daha farklı telaşlarınız var işte
bu noktada bir hatta bir sözle vardı
yani 9-6 yaş işte çalışanlar dokuz altı
işte çalışırlar ama kendi işini yapanlar
7/24 onu yapmak zorundalar ya da belki
günde 15 saatini vermek zorunda da Ama
şu da var sevdiğim bir kitap asla yalnız
deme Keyif veren sizin çok güzel sözleri
var aslında diyor ki hayat riske girip
büyüme veya riske etmeyip belli bir
düzeyde kalma arasında yani bunun da bir
hikayesi var işte Aslan çok güçlü bir
hayvan ve ist galiba avlanabiliyor ve
tarla faresini her istediğinde
avlayabiliyormuş ama
günün sonunda kaç tane fare yerse yesin
hep aç kalıyor Ya işte bazen hayat riske
girip ter dökerek o ceylanın peşinden
gitmeye gerektiriyor ve ben o Ceylan'ın
peşinden koştum Hatta Koşmaya da devam
ediyorum Sadece belli bir bölüm değil
yani bundan sonra da koşmaya devam
edeceğim bir işte o bir sene boyunca
maddi imkansızlıkla çevre baskısıyla
yani her böyle sosyal medyada her
içeriği incelediğim İngilizce Türkçe
sürekli böyle kovaladığım bir dönem
yaşadım o dönemden sonra da yani fırsat
ayağıma geldi ama belki ben fırsata
gittim Bir noktada Ee pandemi dönemime
başlamadan önce dünya satranç
şampiyonluğuna
bir mail atmıştım Orada da bir turnuva
vardı ve turnuva iptal edilmemişti böyle
pandemi döneminin tam hani bütün
turnuvaları iptal oldu bir tane turnuva
Şansıma iptal olmadı o da benim ve dünya
satranç şampiyonunda gideceği bir
turnuvaydı ve ben de şey istemiştim yani
ona mail atıp ona bir röportaj yapmak
istemiştim ve dedim ki bunun
karşılığında sizin şirketlerinizi Ben
Türkiye'de tanıtabilirim diye
söylemiştim ve o mail döndü dolaştı o
şirketin ceosuna sonrasında benimle bir
görüşmeye gitti ve pandemi dönemi tam
böyle lakton geldi ve biz onlarla
Konuşarak bir tane toplantıda ben iş
teklifi aldım Türkçe müdürü oldum
sonrasında Tabii bu çalışma devam etti
yine ilk 3-4 ay sonrasında İngilizce'de
globalde içerik üretmeye başladım
Sonrasında o işte mail döndü dolaştı
derken o mailden Bir sene sonra ben
dünya satranç şampiyonunun artık
kanalını yönetmeye başladım ya işte bu
da tabii şans da var işin içinde ama bir
noktada o 2019'daki verdiğim emeğin de
aslında bir noktada karşılığını almış
olduk işte yani Çok sevdiğim bir satranç
Aslında ünlü bir karşılaşmasında
söylediği sözlerle bitirmek istiyorum
şimdi bir konum var konumda da böyle çok
sakin bir konu eşit bir konu ve
durup dururken bir taş feda ediyor ve o
taş vedasını yaptığınız zaman diğer
taşları da Feda etmek zorundasınız ki
onun bir anlamı olsun ve o taş vedasını
yaptıktan sonra artık konum o kadar iyi
değil ama o planına devam ediyor ve en
son bir taş feda ediyor Bir Taş daha bir
taşla feda ediyor ve oyunu çok güzel bir
şekilde kazanıyor ve sonrasında diyorlar
ki ona ya
sen hani bunların hepsini hesapladın mı
Gerçekten o da diyor ki ya o feda
hamlesini yaparken Aslında bu kadar
ileriyi görmemiştim Ama hayatta risk
almadan da başarıya ulaşılamıyor
teşekkürler
[Alkış]